[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing dark wizards
dementors and how the two groups
interact with one another
more specifically i'm going to be
addressing how dark wizards like
voldemort
have historically been able to control
the dark
non-beings known as dementors in order
to better tackle this topic
it's important to first have a very
clear understanding of what dementors
actually
are as well as how they behave dementors
are amortal
non-beings with dark grey scabby skin
they are cloaked it can reach up to
three meters in height
making them exceptionally intimidating
they represent unhappiness and despair
making them the perfect guards for the
island fortress of azkaban
the prison where all the darkest witches
and wizards are sent to pay for their
crimes
the original concept for dementors was
thought up by jk rowling
as a way of representing depression as
somebody who had experienced depression
herself
rowling wanted to create a creature that
personified all of the negative aspects
of depression
in an interview rowling was asked to
describe
what depression feels like she said the
following
it is that absence of being able to
envisage that you will ever be cheerful
again
the absence of hope that very deadened
feeling
which is so very different from feeling
sad sad hurts but it's a healthy feeling
it's a necessary thing to feel
depression is very different
and that basically sums up what being in
the presence of a dementor is like
they are like moving clouds of
depression and despair
the following excerpt describing harry's
encounter with dementors
in the prisoner of azkaban reinforces
this definition
an intense cold swept over them all
harry felt his own breath
catch in his chest the cold went deeper
than his skin
it was inside his chest it was inside
his very heart
harry's eyes rolled up into his head he
couldn't see
he was drowning and cold there was a
rushing in his ears as though of water
he was being dragged downward the
roaring growing louder
and then from far away he heard
screaming
terrible terrified pleading screams
he wanted to help whoever it was he
tried to move his arms
but couldn't a thick white fog was
swirling around him
inside him okay so now you've got a good
idea of what dementors are
but the question remains how can dark
wizards like voldemort control them
they certainly don't sound like type of
creature that one would be able to
control
but as it happens both the ministry of
magic the good guys
and dark forces have controlled
dementors at one point or another
as it turns out dementors have served
for a long time
the ministry of magic first hired
dementors back in 1718
when new minister for magic damocles
raul
was elected raul saw the dementors as a
potential asset
and rather than trying to get rid of
them felt that he could utilize their
abilities at azkaban helping to keep
dark prisoners in check
knowing that the prison needed guards
raul felt that by using
extant non-beings like dementors he
would be able to prevent endangering the
lives
of witch or wizard guards wizard kind
protested the use of dementors at first
but because of the near zero percent
breakout rate at azkaban
people eventually just moved on from the
issue
so dementors ended up being the perfect
guards but
why you might ask now would deventers
serve the ministry of magic
why would dark demented non-beings serve
the ministry
well there are a few reasons the main
reason was that the ministry allowed the
dementors to feed on the emotions of the
prisoners within its walls
this was one of the primary issues with
using dementors at azkaban
in the first place as there are
certainly some ethical issues to be
considered here
the only thing that dementors want to do
is feed so it makes sense that
if handed to them on a silver platter
they would jump at the opportunity
this was a win-win for everyone as it
also served as an additional deterrent
for dark wizards
not to break wizarding law in the first
place in my opinion
evil witches and wizards were probably
far more likely to break laws
before the prospect of facing dementors
the next
and lesser reason that dementors
followed ministry orders
was simply the fact that the ministry
held some level of control over them
via the patronus charm we see umbridge
leveraging her patronus to control
dementors
in chapter 13 of the deathly hallows at
the foot of the platform
a bright silver long head cat prowled up
and down
up and down up and down and harry
realized that it was there to protect
the prosecutors
from the despair that emanated from the
dementors that was for the accused to
feel
not the accusers a patronus charm is
produced when a witch or wizard casts
the spell
expecto patronum there are two types of
patronus charms
corporeal and incorporeal and the type
that a witch or wizard casts will depend
on their experience
preference the more basic form of the
spell is the incorporeal patronus which
assumes no animal form
and simply resembles a burst of white
vapour or smoke and the more advanced
form of the spell
is the conjuring of a corporeal patronus
the purpose of a patronus is almost
exclusively to ward off dementors and
its usage
dates back many many centuries the
reason that the patronus charm is so
effective against dementors
is that it basically represents
everything that dementors detest
light happiness and purity besides the
patronus charm
there's no real reason that dementors
would follow ministry instructions
though i am of the impression that if
the dementors did want to take over the
ministry
they possibly could at least for a
little while as not every witch and
wizard
is actually capable of casting a
patronus now you might be asking
if the patronus charm is how the
ministry controls dementors
then how on earth do dark wizards
control them most
dark wizards are simply unable to cast a
patronus charm
and that's because in order to cast one
you need to harness happy memories
furthermore it's dangerous territory for
dark wizards as we learn in the tale of
ilius and the dark wizard rexidian
that attempting to cast a patronus charm
when you are unworthy
has dire consequences enraged riccian
decided to enter the fray himself
and tried to summon a patronus to ward
off elias's mouse
however he failed to remember that only
the pure of heart can produce a patronus
and thus for the first time in history
it was revealed what happens
when a combatant but unworthy wizard or
witch attempts the spell
maggots shot out of ricidian's wand and
quickly devoured him
as they engulfed his entire body there
are obviously exceptions
like dolores umbridge who can cast a
patronus
but most can't so how have dark wizards
historically controlled them
as revealed in the following quote from
dumbledore death eaters simply have
more to offer than the ministry the rest
of us
sleep less soundly in our beds cornelius
knowing that you have put lord
voldemort's most dangerous supporters
in the care of creatures who will join
him the instant he asks them
said dumbledore they will not remain
loyal to you fudge
voldemort can offer them much more scope
for their powers and their pleasures
than you can
with the dementors behind him and his
old supporters returned to him
you will be hard-pressed to stop him
regaining the sort of power he had 13
years ago
if we look at the offerings of each side
good versus bad
in the context of a meal the ministry is
offering dementors the souls of corrupt
dark witches and wizards that likely
don't have much left for them to take
there isn't much meat left prisoners of
azkaban
are there for a reason they've committed
atrocities and made sacrifices in their
lives
at the cost of their soul some living
cursed existences
for a dark creature that thrives on
darkness and despair
the soul of a regular witch or wizard is
much more
appetizing to them if that makes sense
the ministry is allowing them to feed on
a couple of prisoners
voldemort is offering them free reign to
feed on the entire wizarding population
furthermore dementors thrive in
conditions of darkness and despair
and nothing brings despair quite like
rule under lord voldemort
quite simply death eaters and dark
wizards can offer dementors more than
the ministry
so it's just a logical move for
dementors to switch sides according to
who is in or will be in power though i
must say
that i do wonder if the abundance of
darkness offered by voldemort's regime
would eventually backfire on him
dementors reproduce
in conditions of despair darkness and in
the environment offered by voldemort
their numbers would surge given that
dark witches wizards
are more or less defenseless against
dementors no patronus
are they really in a position of power
and that's it for this video
did you ever wonder how dementors were
controlled let me know in the comment
section
below until next time happiness can be
found
even in the darkest of times if one only
remembers to turn
on the light
you